Margot Robbie is known for taking on
challenging roles that portray
fascinating characters so it should be
no surprise that she had a specific
condition for playing the most
recognizable doll in the world it might
be hard to imagine anybody besides
Margot Robbie as Barbie even though
there were originally other actors
attached to the long-awaited Barbie
movie still according to a new article
in time Robbie wouldn't have taken the
movie if she was the only one playing
Barbie
Barbie Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi
Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi
as the piece explains Robbie's Barbie
definitely is the traditional version of
the character people remember blonde
blonde hair long tan legs pink outfits
the works but after Mattel introduced a
much wider variety of Barbies into its
roster it made it possible for the movie
to depict the world's most famous doll
in many new ways in fact Robbie revealed
that without other Barbies she wouldn't
have been interested in the role saying
if Mattel hadn't made that change to
have a multiplicity of Barbies I don't
think I would have wanted to attempt to
make a Barbie film I don't think you
should say this is the one version of
what Barbie is and that's what women
should aspire to be and look like and
act like Issa Rae agreed with Robbie
saying that the sheer diversity of the
cast is what helped sell her on the
Barbie movie as a whole speaking with
time she said my worry was that it was
going to feel too white feministy but I
think that it's self-aware Barbie land
is perfect right it represents
Perfection so if Perfection is just a
bunch of white Barbies I don't know that
anybody can get on board with that the
CEO and president of Mattel Richard
Dixon made the argument that for people
who only have one version of Barbie
already in their head Robbie's portrayal
as the proto-barby is simply a gateway
to the others saying of course she looks
like Barbie but they're all Barbie it's
the perfect cast to express what Barbie
is today and Margot is the bridge Hari
Neff who plays Dr Barbie in the film
came into the project with her lived
experience as a trans woman and she also
felt comfortable with and excited by the
project thanks to writer director Greta
Gerwig she said I knew this was not
going to shy away from the parts of
Barbie that are more interesting but
potentially a little bit more fraught
the contemporary history of feminism and
body positivity there are questions of
how Barbie can fit into all of that as
for what the Barbie movie is about a lot
of the plot details have been kept Under
Wraps but fans of writer director Greta
Gerwig and her co-writer and real-life
partner Noah Bombeck know that this
movie probably has plenty of exciting
tricks up its bright pink sleeve what we
do know is that when she starts thinking
about death too much and her arched feet
to go flat Robbie's Barbie and her Ken
head to the real world to figure out how
to solve this admittedly bizarre problem
[Music]
[Laughter]
no seriously no comments in the
timepiece the cast remained fairly mum
about specific plot details but Mattel
Executives had some comments that turned
out to be pretty interesting Beyond
admitting that they'd always hoped
Robbie would play Barbie executive
producer of Mattel films Robbie Brenner
said that Barbie is not a feminist movie
Robbie had an interesting response to
that saying it's not that it is or it
isn't it's a movie it's a movie that's
got so much in it the point is that
we're in on the joke this isn't a Barbie
puff piece with all the anticipation
building for the Barbie movie are the
powers that be eyeing a sequel it
probably won't shock you to learn that
the Mattel Executives aren't against the
idea Mattel CEO Enon Christ specifically
says that there's a possibility of more
Barbie movies but Robbie once again
demurred it could go a million different
directions from this point but I think
you fall into a bit of a trap if you try
and set up a first movie whilst also
planning for sequels
foreign